if you want to hear what advice jeff
bezos Elon Musk Gary Vaynerchuk and
other entrepreneurs have for kids then
this video is for you be proud not of
your gifts but of your hard work and
your choices really pay attention to
negative feedback and solicit it
particularly from friends the best way
to become something is to act like
something
what's up believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so to help you and maybe the
younger people in your family on your
journey today we're gonna learn what
some of the best entrepreneurs in the
world their advice is for kids enjoy
coming up first is be on the lookout for
your passions with Jeff Bezos did you
know you wanted to do this when you are
a kid yes well not this particular
expedition but it's a very good question
you know what ever since I was five
years old that's when Neil Armstrong
stepped onto the surface of the Moon
I've been kind of passionate about space
rockets rocket engines space travel I
became a science fiction reader and I've
always known that I wanted to do
something having to do with space and
I've spent a lot of time thinking about
it for really almost my whole life and
that's one of the things you guys will
find that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift I think we all have
passions and you don't get to choose
them they pick you but you have to be
alert to them you have to be looking for
them and when you find your passion it's
a fantastic gift for you because it
gives you direction it gives you purpose
you could have a job or you can have a
career or you can have a calling and the
best thing is to have a calling and if
you find your passion you'll have that
and all your work won't feel like work
to you
number two is learn how to code do you
know what a computer programmer is
no no no when you're programming you're
teaching possibly the stupidest thing in
the entire universe a computer how to do
something programming is one of the only
things in the world that that you can do
where you can sit down and just make
something completely new from scratch
you know whatever whatever you want it's
really not unlike kind of playing an
instrument or something or you know or
playing a sport it starts out being very
intimidating but kind of get the hang of
it over time coding it is something that
can be learned and I know it can be
intimidating a lot of things are
intimidating but you know what isn't I
was obsessed with maps when I was a when
I was a kid and cities specifically so I
taught myself how to program but at a
very clear goal of what I wanted to do
which is to see a map of the city on my
screen and play with it put things on
the map move things around the map see
what was happening in the city how it
worked how it lived were used the best
early thing was actually using software
to decide when the classes in my school
would mean and that put me in a position
decide which girls were in my class
while I was in his after-school group
called the whiskas and when people found
that they laughed at me and you know all
these things and I'm like man I don't
care I think it's cool and you know I'm
learning a lot and some of my friends
have jobs it's important for these kids
it should be mandatory to be a citizen
on this planet to read and write code
I just think you have to start small
right and I think that's one of the
biggest misconceptions about computer
science and programming over all is that
you have to learn this big body of
information before you can do anything
you don't have to be a genius to know
how to code you need to be determined
additions subtractions
that that's about it should probably
know your multiplication tables you
don't have to be a genius to code you
have to be a genius to read do you have
to be a genius to do math no no I think
if someone had told me that software is
really about humanity that it's really
about helping people by using computer
technology it would have changed my
outlook a lot earlier whether you're
trying to make a lot of money or whether
you just want to change the world
computer program is an incredibly
empowering skill to learn to be able to
actually come up with an idea and then
see it in your hands and then be able to
press a button and have it be in
millions of people's hands I mean I
think we're the first generation in the
world that's really ever had that kind
of experience the programmers of
tomorrow are the Wizards of the future
you know you're gonna look like you have
magic powers compared to everybody else
I think it's amazing it's it I think
it's the closest thing we have to a
superpower great coders are today's
rockstars
that's it up at number three is applied
the physics technique with Elon Musk you
take crazy risks you bet you bet your
fortune on it and you seem to have done
that multiple times I mean almost no one
can do that is that we have some of that
secret sauce can we put it into our
education system can someone learn from
you it is truly amazing what you've done
Thanks thank you well I think there I do
think there's a good good framework for
thinking it is physics you know the sort
of first principles reasoning but
generally that I think they're what what
I mean by that is boil things down to
that they're fundamental truths and
reason up from there as opposed to
reasoning by analogy through most of our
life we we get through life by reasoning
by analogy which essentially means kind
of copying what other people do with
slight variations and you have to do
that otherwise it's mentally you
wouldn't be able to get through the day
but when you when you want to do
something new you you have to you have
to apply the physics approach get
physics is really sort of figured out
how to discover new things that are
counterintuitive like quantum mechanics
it's really counterintuitive so I think
I think that's an important thing to do
and then also to really pay attention to
negative feedback and solicit it
particularly from friends this may sound
like sort of simple advice but it's
hardly anyone does that and and it's
incredibly helpful
boys and girls watching study physics
coming in at number four is explore the
world with Neil deGrasse Tyson
okay so what you have to tell everyone
there because I can't if I repeat it if
you think I'm lying
love those fractions yes okay if you're
asking those questions now you'll be the
deepest thinking adult there never was
so what is the meaning of life I think
people ask that question on the
assumption that meaning is something you
could look for and then I found it
here's the meaning is what it is I've
been looking for it okay and it doesn't
consider the possibility that maybe
meaning in life is something that you
create you manufactured for yourself and
for others and so when I think of
meaning in life
I asked have I learned something today
that I didn't know yesterday bringing me
a little closer to knowing all that can
be known in the universe just a little
closer however far away all the
knowledge sits I'm a little closer if I
end of the day and I don't know a little
more that day than the day before I
think I wasted that day so the people
who at the end of the school year say
the summer I don't have to think anymore
I'm thinking
what the to learn is to become closer to
nature and to learn how things work
gives you power to influence events
gives you power to help people who may
need it power to help yourselves to
shape or trajectory so when I think of
what is the meaning of life to me that's
not an eternal unanswerable question to
me that is an arm's reach of me everyday
and so for you at age six and
three-quarters may I suggest that for
you you should explore nature as much as
you possibly can and occasionally that
means getting your clothes dirty because
you might want to jump into puddles and
your parents don't want you to do that I
gave you permission
so howdy I'm gonna give you more
permission for more things you ready
have you ever pulled all the pots and
pans out of the cabinet before and hit
them with the wooden spoon have you done
that yet have you done that he said in a
way then what was it what did your
parents say when you did when you did
that well you did it with paper plates
that's not nearly as fun okay so you
have my permission to pull lots of pans
out of the cabinets and bang on them
with spoons and knives and things
you're still a kid and and and part of
being a kid is exploring the world
around you and while all the way the
laws of nature influence that world so
take different pots of ants and hit them
with a spoon and they'll all sound
different they'll sound different with
different spoons some pans are aluminum
summer steel some copper will sound
different and that's kind of a fun
experiment and most parents will say
don't do that they're getting them dirty
stop doing that you're making too much
noise you tell them that why did you
have me in the first place
just reminder that they didn't your kids
so that they could keep having a neat
house okay
because kids make things messy and
there's a reason why they make things
messy because they're exploring the
world around them and so you have my
permission now if you get in trouble I'm
not gonna be around right okay so your
meaning of life will be enhanced if
you're given as much freedom as you can
to explore the world then when you get
older you will become so close to how
the world works that when a problem
arises that needs a solution you will
say I know how to solve that I've been
thinking about that before and I've been
thinking about that ever since I was
banging the pans on the kitchen floor
but ever since I jumped it with two feet
into a puddle or ever since I walked
coming out at Clarke snowflakes in my
mouth down the stream did you do that
today when it snowed was the last time
you cooked snowflakes in America okay
you see the problem here okay
the dogs have forgotten how to embrace
nature how to think about the natural
world so you will owe it to yourself and
everyone else who will be cured by some
medicine you may event one day you owe
it to yourself and to everyone else to
continue to stay curious
and by doing so you will have created
the meaning in life that others think is
waiting under a rock for them one day
and you would have made it happen all on
your own
so thanks for your question next is
number five choose to do hard things
with Jeff Bezos in your life what
obstacles that you faced before you
achieve success did positivity help you
in some ways and how did you come up
with the solution wow that's a good a
good philosophical question and you know
we all have adversity in our lives I
doubt if you really you know if you know
somebody any friend or anybody that you
talk to there's no lack of adversity and
by the way that's good because it's what
teaches us how to get back up you fall
down you get back up it always happens
and you know you get certain gifts in
life and you want to take advantage of
those but you like it's my advice on
adversity and success would be to be
proud not of your gifts but of your hard
work and your choices so you know you
may be the kinds of gifts you get like
you know you might be really good at
math it might be really easy for you
that's a kind of gift but practicing
that math and taking it to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you you can
be grateful for them and thankful for
them and but your choices you choose to
card you choose to do hard things those
are choices that you can be proud of at
number six is model success with Gary
Vaynerchuk I want to be an entrepreneur
when I get older but I don't know where
to start like what action should I be
taking right now as a kid the best way
to become something is to act like
something so you want to be an
entrepreneur start acting like one
meaning start a business start selling
things both will work or find a mentor
find the 18 19 20 21 year old kind of
entrepreneur in your neighborhood and
start helping her or him out for free
just to learn the hustle to taste the
game you've got to put yourself in the
position there's no reading about
entrepreneurship next is number seven
have iron skin with Logan Paul so what
advice you give to someone who's eight
years old who wants to put content up
and of all the haters that may comment
and just like destroy his heart so tough
it's horrible it's horrible but my mom
goes I want to do vlogs my mom vlogs
guys she's got like 700,000 subscribers
this is my mother she's 55 when she goes
I want to do vlogs I'm like mom you have
no idea the Internet is gonna tear you
apart no I'm fine
week later calls me sobbing look at you
all these people are saying about me my
wrinkles really that bad am I not funny
I'm like mom I told you you gotta have
iron skin but as an eight-year-old it's
hard to have iron skin because you're
eight so I'd say I'd say if you got a if
you know you want to be a youtuber and
an influencer just know that hey is
coming the negative comments are good
when I had acne in college or I was
doing vines and like I get comments like
you look like a burn victim whatever I'm
like oh like they heard me but at the
end of the day you do cares there's like
five of them
at number eight is work hard with Ashton
Kutcher I believe that opportunity looks
a lot like hard work when I was 13 I had
my first job with my dad carrying
shingles up to the roof and then I got a
job washing dishes at a restaurant and
then I got a job in a grocery store deli
and then I got a job in a factory
sweeping cheerio dust off the ground and
I've never had a job in my life that I
was better than I was always just lucky
to have a job and every job I had was a
stepping stone to my next job and I
never quit my job until I had my next
job and so opportunities look a lot like
work number 9 is following your dreams
with APJ Abdul Kalam so how did you
become so great holiday become so great
that's a question well which classier
City what's your dream in life single
monogamy anything any music well I don't
know how big you know give the relative
terms so I personally believe you Basava
dream say you must say I must have a
dream
I must continuously acquire knowledge
continuously acquire knowledge hard work
hard work and perseverance one should
not be a one not afraid of problems be
successful okay and number ten is a
special bonus message for me hi my name
is Derrick I'm 15 years old and I'm a
freshman in high school I really want to
start my own business but I really don't
know where to start I have a few ideas
in mind do you think you could give me
some advice you need to apply every day
to do something in your business 30 to
60 minutes at least every single day and
this is for anybody anybody who who has
a life outside of their business whether
you have a job whether you're in high
school whether you university whether
you're doing something else you have
this dream that you want to go out and
do but you have a lot of other
responsibilities and often what you find
is those things take away from your time
to actually run your business and so you
need to make sure that you're taking
action every single day that you're
building momentum for your business for
your idea even if you don't know what
the next best step is because there is
no perfect steps in building a business
there's a lot of stuff that you have to
do and test and try to build momentum
for but making sure that you're putting
the time in because I think too many
people spend too much time up here too
much time thinking and making the
perfect plane and and not enough time
actually doing you got to get out and
actually do and make time for it
consistently 30 to 60 minutes every
single day on your business to start
building momentum thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know what you thought of this video
was a bit of an experiment for myself or
my team so let me know what you think
leaving the comments below I'd also love
to know which piece of advice resonated
the most with you what do you want to
here with the kids in your life your
nieces or nephews or sons or daughters
or friends cousins whatever who do you
want to share this with what message
resonated the most with you and is there
some bonus rules that you would add on
the list yourself is there an 11 12 13
that I'm missing that you want to add on
leave it in the comments below so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love see you soon
raise your standard apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion and not one drop of
my self-worth depends on your that's
something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top 10 rows of success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details